plus
[Musique]
oui
mais
aux échos
au bout
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas parce que jamais en public je
leur parle revanche fait seul sait pas
puisque je suis l'offre de ma vie écrit
jean t shirt c'est pas pour ça que je
suis content parce que
[Musique]
je me sens pas parce que je te regarde
et fait sept ans que je suis confiant je
me sens pas je suis là je suis le père
préfère
[Musique]
il
j'ai mon plan c'est pas parce que tu
pars faire que ta force et non pas parce
que je te connais par coeur
[Musique]
c'est pas parce que je suis pas partant
c'est pas parce que je dors de toi c'est
pas que je côtoie des stars que je vois
aps les histoires que j'ai passé une
bonne soirée
pas sûr j'ai pris je serai pas
allez
[Musique]
nivet
mais on pensait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
ok c'est bon